Uh, Donald Trump appears totally off the rails.
And our recent series of tweets about the
moon and Mars, uh, the tweets are as bonkers
as they are hypocritical, neither of which
is a shock from the current president.
Now, I've been talking about space exploration
and NASA funding forever on this program.
And sadly there's a big part of the country
that doesn't see the importance of space exploration.
And there was another part of the country
that likes space exploration, but only as
a military industrial complex sort of testing
ground for new weapons and military tack or
as part of expanding American empire and colonialism
to space.
But in reality, exploring space is a really
important, uh, thing for humans and important
endeavor for humans to undertake.
The ambition and curiosity element are part
of it, but that's kind of a more general thing.
There's a lifesaving component, right?
Having the ability to save huge numbers of
people from asteroids and comets, but by being
able to deflect them could be a really big
thing for humanity in the future.
Depending on how long we think humans can
stay on planet earth.
At a certain point we're going to need some
other place to go.
If Homo sapiens is going to continue existing
earth is not going to be home to humans forever,
it'll probably still be home for a long time.
But if we want a place to eventually go, we
need to be exploring space.
Space exploration could lead to huge developments
in mitigating climate change.
We don't know what's out there and what we
might find and what developments might stem
from there.
So Anyway, Republicans sometimes want to explore
space.
Sometimes they don't.
Sometimes they want to do it, but only with
private industry instead of NASA.
Sometimes NASA is okay and Donald Trump tweeted
over the weekend that we shouldn't go to the
moon and the moon is part of Mars.
I guess he means like in a more general sense
of space exploration.
Donald Trump tweeting very strangely quote
for all of the money we are spending, NASA
should not be talking about going to the moon.
We did that 50 years ago.
They should be focused on the much bigger
things we are doing, including Mars, of which
the moon is apart defense and science.
But Trump later tweeting also that moon pie
is not really made of moon rocks.
Right in the, in the, under the category of
what is extraordinarily obvious.
So the immediate reaction was is Trump saying
that the moon is part of Mars?
Uh, what is wrong with this guy?
What the Hell is going on?
He's weaponized ignorance.
Now all of those reactions are true and accurate,
but I don't think Trump thinks the moon is
part of Mars.
I believe what Donald Trump is trying to say
here is something like the moon is part of
the eventual Martian project.
Going to the moon in and of itself is a means
and not an end or something like that.
I mean, I don't exactly know what he was trying
to say, but the most important thing is that
this is the opposite of what Donald Trump
said three weeks ago, three weeks ago.
Donald Trump tweeted on May 13th under my
administration, we are restoring NASA to greatness
and we are going back to the moon.
Then Mars, I am updating my budget to include
an additional one point $6 billion so that
we can return to space in a big way.
But then over the weekend he says, NASA should
not be talking about going to the moon.
We did that 50 years ago.
We should be exploring space.
No matter what Donald Trump says, we should
be funding it.
So much technology has come as a derivative
from space exploration.
And as far as Donald Trump drunk Trump's tweets
here, I don't think he literally believes
the moon is part of Mars.
Um, I think that we should stop trying to
read so much into his tweets.
These are the rantings of an ignorant and
unstable person, period.
If you imagine, you know, being on the Boston
or New York subway for example, which I've
had the privilege of doing hundreds of times,
you don't necessarily try to read into the
specifics of what the guy urinating in the
back of the subway car is saying about Jesus
is coming.
Right?
You, you don't, you recognize it for what
it is.
You understand the context and you say it's
not really worth trying to read into.
So specifically, I think we increasingly need
to see Donald Trump's tweets in sort of the
same way.
These are the erratic unhinged, uh, things
that occur to Donald Trump and that he tweets
before anybody can actually talk sense into
him.
I don't know exactly what he meant by the
moon is part of Mars.
What I do know is that in just three and a
half weeks, Donald Trump appears to have completely
done a one 80 on whether we should be doing
this space exploration and whether we should
be going to the moon.
And that's the real concern.
And that's the concern Geo, politically, when
Donald Trump's whims change and it makes it
so that other countries can't see the United
States as a reliable negotiating partner,
as a reliable partner in all sorts of different
ways, which they rightly can't under Donald
Trump because as we've seen with the Iran
deal, he will on a whim say, even though Iran
hasn't violated it, I'm just going to bail
out.
That's the real danger here.
Uh, just Trump think the moon is a piece of
Mars.
I don't think so.
Uh, but who knows what Trump really actually
thinks.
I'm curious what you think Trump meant by
this tweet.